buenas noches estamos de regreso para
actualizar toda la información en
materia económica junto a daniela
hablando un periodista experta de
nuestra red de acción también la vamos a
comenzar hablando de las tensiones entre
francia y turquía que no son sólo
políticas también económicas verdad sí
señor santiago muy buenas noches del
gobierno de turquía llamó a la unión
europea a detener la agenda que calificó
de anti islámica por parte del
presidente francés emmanuel macrón esto
después de que se endurecieran en este
país de las normas contra el extremismo
islámico el líder turco invitó a sus
ciudadanos a que no compren bienes
franceses como ya sabemos pero para
saber de qué vienes estamos hablando
santiago damos un repaso a la relación
comercial entre estos dos países el
comercio binacional anual suma cerca de
14 mil millones de dólares
francia es el décimo proveedor de
turquía y le vende aviones productos de
hierro y acero y automóviles con sus
repuestos de hecho nosotros franceses le
doy el dato son los más vendidos en tour
quiere por el lado turco francia es su
séptimo comprador en especial de
camiones
accesorios y maquinaria también
dispositivos electrónicos la atención se
nota también en el mercado santiago la
lira turca cayó a mínimos históricos el
día de hoy pues continuamos en el
continente americano en américa latina
porque bueno tras un histórico
plebiscito chile se encamina a tener una
nueva constitución que también
implicaría cambios en materia económica
si la explosión social hace un año se
dio básicamente por la brecha social ya
que chile es uno de los países más
desiguales entre las naciones en
desarrolladas hoy en día el 10 por
ciento de la población más rica del país
recibe casi el 40 por ciento de todos
los ingresos pero el país también ha
gozado de un sostenido crecimiento
económico que muchos atribuyen a su
sistema de libre mercado lo que se
espera según expertos es que esa nueva
constitución ayude justamente a
disminuir la brecha a otros pilares las
pensiones la atención médica y la
educación que hoy son privados
escuchamos
han sido los jóvenes los que se
pronunciaron claramente en favor de un
cambio en la política económica y la
sociedad en su conjunto acompañó esta
demanda fundamentalmente por el régimen
de pensiones que es un régimen de
capitalización que no ha dado las
respuestas que requieren los sectores
que han aportado a ese sistema la
desigualdad de los sectores de ingresos
fijos es indudable que el pueblo chileno
viene a poner nuevamente en discusión el
sistema distributivo y el acceso a los
bienes comunes
bueno a ver si le vamos a brasil donde
los altos precios del arroz estando que
están causando polémica ni a un país
donde es un alimento esencial sin
santiago el precio del arroz este año ha
subido un 20 por ciento en brasil
empiezo con eso y está tan alto que hace
poco el gobierno se vio obligado a
reducir temporalmente los aranceles para
importarlo esto santiago a pesar de que
este país es uno de los mayores
productores del mundo no solamente
consumidores este lunes un ciudadano
recriminó al presidente ya ir bolsonaro
y está
la respuesta que se llevó
los hombres más apropiados
de brasil eeuu daniela para hablar de la
venta de vivienda no que en el mes de
septiembre tuvo una caída inesperada sí
señor se vendieron 900 59 mil unidades
es decir un 35 por ciento menos que en
igual mes del año pasado los analistas
esperaban más ventas este mes gracias a
que las tasas hipotecarias han estado
históricamente bajas pero parece que el
impulso tardará poco
incertidumbre electoral queda atrás y
los mercados comienzan a hacer reajustes
esto sugeriría que podríamos tener tasas
hipotecarias más altas el próximo año y
en consecuencia veremos una gran
disminución en la capacidad de acceso a
vivienda bueno continuamos con los
indicadores de la jornada que dicen hubo
grandes caídas en todo el mundo por
cuenta de la explosión de casos de kobe
19 pérdidas cercanas al 2 por ciento en
cada índice de bolsa en europa los
mercados tuvieron su peor día en un mes
alemania se llevó la peor parte con un
descenso cercano al 4% pero si vamos a
américa latina a los inversionistas en
poco les gustaron
estos resultados del referendo en chile
cuyo principal índice perdió casi un 3%
y la bolsa de argentina partió más del 5
por ciento en su país la nivelación
gracias por esta completísima crónica en
economía nuestra audiencia le invitamos
a continuar informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación
[Música]